Sequels to movies will always
come with its bumps in the road,
but for Jake Sully? He may have a bit
of a boring, confusing story problem.
After 13 years, "Avatar: The Way of Water" has
brought viewers back to Pandora and into the life
of ex-Marine-turned-full-time-blue-person Jake
Sully. Reactions to "Avatar 2" have been strong,
and for good reason — it's visually stunning,
utterly immersive, and far better on the
narrative front than its predecessor. In
short, it's everything a sequel should be.
Given how much cutting-edge technology
James Cameron brought to bear for the film,
it should be no surprise that
"The Way of Water" looks stunning,
and unlike any other film ever made before.
By leaping into the future and giving Jake and
Neytiri a whole family to look out for, "Avatar 2"
adds several meaningful layers to the narrative.
The result is a relatively simple but emotionally
affecting story about parenthood, growing up, and
protecting the things you love. Unfortunately,
"The Way of Water" is still built on the
shaky foundation that is the original movie.
“And I was hoping for some tactical
plan that didn’t involve martyrdom.”
This doesn't hurt the film too badly when it's
focused on new characters or big cinematic set
pieces, but it becomes glaringly obvious whenever
Jake is back in the spotlight. While the reformed
jarhead is markedly better in the sequel, he can't
escape the problems of his past. Despite its best
efforts, "Avatar: The Way of Water" can't
shake its predecessor's Jake Sully problem.
The sad fact is that Jake Sully is a terrible
protagonist — and barely half a character — in the
original "Avatar." Sam Worthington does his best
to bring some life and charm to the ex-marine,
but the material he's given to work with is just
pitiful. For those who haven't seen the movie
since its original release in 2009, let's
do a little recap of Jake's character arc.
Paraplegic ex-marine Jake Sully arrives on
Pandora to take the place of his scientist
twin brother, whose avatar was fully
completed before his untimely death.
Jake is given the opportunity
to learn the ways of the Na'vi,
but he's actually spying on them for the
Resources Development Administration.
After spending three months without once
mentioning the impending danger to their land,
Jake is cast out by Neytiri when
the humans bulldoze Hometree. He
then tames a big bird that only five
Na'vi in history have ever ridden,
immediately regains the full trust of the clan,
and leads them to victory as their new chosen one.
Aside from being grossly white savior-y and
pretty ableist, Jake's story just flat-out
doesn't make sense. The only reason he's welcomed
as a hero by the Na'vi is that he tames the toruk,
but doing so is so simple that it drains the
act of any weight. We learn nothing about his
past besides his military service record,
and we're never given a real reason to root
for him. We're told that Jake is the main
character, but he doesn't earn the title.
The good news is that Jake is
way more interesting in "Avatar:
The Way of Water." The bad news is that the
film can't fully fix his problems from the
first film. Making Jake a protective father
who's scared for his kids is a great move,
and it leads to a far more compelling arc
than the one in the first movie. But James
Cameron still wants us to believe that Jake is
the hero of heroes, and it just doesn't work.
The Sullys' arrival on the reefs of the Metkayina
would have been a perfect opportunity to unpack
some things from the first film. Clan leaders
Ronal and Tonowari are hesitant at first to
let them stay, pointing out their mixed-blood
features as a reason that they wouldn't fit in.
However, they stop short of questioning
Jake's legitimacy as a Na'vi leader. It
would make sense for Ronal to ask some
questions like why are so many Na'vi
following this guy? Didn't he just lie to us
for three months and then ride a giant bird?
But posing those questions would be putting all
of "Avatar" into question, which is something
Cameron clearly isn't willing to do. Granted, it's
been nearly two decades of Jake proving himself,
but Tonowari would still be right to
remain suspicious of Jake's origins.
Yes, Jake humbles himself a bit and becomes
more vulnerable in "Avatar 2," but it's not
enough to redeem his character. He still
refers to himself as a "dumb grunt," so
why is he received like a legendary leader?
Maybe Cameron just can't let go of the heroic
space marine myth. But given how outright evil
the RDA is, that message is confused at best.